[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un repaso por las principales
noticias las más importantes
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 a continuación les presento los temas
que tenemos para esta misión
algunos países de centroamérica viven en
una doble emergencia por un lado la
pandemia del hobby 19 que no da tregua y
sigue dejando varias víctimas y
contagios y por el otro la destrucción
que dejaron los huracanes esta idiota y
también el reto que tienen las
autoridades y los ciudadanos allí es
enorme vamos a conversar con uno de
nuestros corresponsales nuestro
corresponsal jorge hurtado en la ciudad
de managua en nicaragua méxico superó
las 100.000 víctimas por kobe 19 este
país se convierte así en el cuarto a
nivel mundial en superar este umbral de
fallecidos el mismo gobierno mexicano
reconoció que la cifra puede ser aún
mayor debido al sub diagnóstico vamos a
conversar también con mario' carbonell
nuestro corresponsal lecciones de méxico
para conocer detalles de la situación en
este país y en eeuu lo hemos visto a lo
largo de esta semana el avance de la
pandemia es a pasos agigantados el
número de contagiados aumentó un millón
solamente en una semana y llega así a un
total de 11 millones de casos
diagnosticados las autoridades de
estados como nueva york'
fue anteriormente el foco en la primera
ola comienzan a adoptar medidas de cara
al invierno como el cierre de las
escuelas les vamos a contar más detalles
también con nuestra corresponsable allí
en la ciudad de nueva york
mamen sala vamos a comenzar entonces en
centroamérica en donde comenta les decía
se vive una doble emergencia millones de
personas están padeciendo las
dificultades tras el paso de los
huracanes eta y posteriormente unas
semanas después yo está por países como
honduras nicaragua el salvador y
guatemala países que ya de antemano
tenían muchas dificultades para hacer
frente a la pandemia de kobe 19 por una
infraestructura deficiente y que pues
ahora está aún más afectada por este
fenómeno climático la falta de agua
potable las inundaciones la falta de
electricidad y sobre todo el
hacinamiento en los refugios está
empeorando el panorama para los
ciudadanos veamos
temporada de huracanes en tiempos de
pandemia un cóctel que agrava aún más la
situación de emergencia sanitaria y
económica en centroamérica por el kobe
19 el impacto de la tormenta tropical yo
está deja un reguero de devastación a su
paso que se suma a los impactos del
virus en una región donde la
vulnerabilidad de las personas y las
desigualdades eran ya alarmantes la
región ha sido golpeada por la pandemia
de kobe 19 que actualmente cuenta con
más de 260 mil casos registrados las
organizaciones humanitarias alertan
sobre un posible aumento de contagios
como consecuencia de los huracanes y el
hacinamiento en albergues donde hay unas
30.000 personas en nicaragua país de
entrada de la depresión tropical el
número de contagios roza los 6000 y
cuenta con al menos 159 muertos pero las
asociaciones médicas nicaragüenses han
insistido al gobierno en que muestre los
datos reales de la pandemia mientras que
en honduras las deficiencias del sistema
sanitario precarizaron el trabajo de la
primera línea de batalla contra la
enfermedad de los hospitales donde más
de 70 miembros del personal médico
fallecieron por el cob y 19 cifras del
pasado agosto son víctimas de un sistema
envío
a pelear una guerra sin los insumos
necesarios para poder tener
en la posibilidad de triunfar y el
salvador donde desde el inicio de la
pandemia se impusieron fuertes
restricciones de movilidad registran más
de 36.000 positivos guatemala es el país
con más decesos por la pandemia
centroamérica con casi 4.000 y suma más
de 115 mil contagios por su parte
colombia uno de los países más golpeados
en américa latina' sus islas caribeñas
de san andrés y providencia cuentan con
dos mil cuatro contagios pero las
infraestructuras han quedado totalmente
arrasadas por el huracán las
inundaciones y la falta de insumos que
dificultarán aún más la lucha contra la
pandemia
vamos a conocer más detalles con jorge
hurtado nuestro corresponsal en la
ciudad de managua la capital de
nicaragua hola jorge gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en kobe 19 la semana
en américa y cuéntenos cuál es la
situación que se está viviendo allí en
la región del noreste de nicaragua que
es la región del litoral caribe y que ha
sido la más afectada por el paso de
estos dos huracanes y pues nos sobra
decirlo también está muy afectada por la
pandemia del joven 19
definitivamente el paso de estos dos
portales ha sido devastador inclusive
este último y otra específicamente ha
sido el huracán más fuerte que ha
llegado a este país desde que se tiene
registros históricos hasta el momento se
contabilizan más de 20 muertes y más de
60 mil personas fueron obligadas a
moverse de su sitio debido al riesgo que
corría y estuvieron refugiados en
albergues
juegas iglesias hospitales que sirvieron
de refugio en su momento hasta ahora el
gobierno afirma que enviado más de 300
toneladas de ayuda humanitaria para
responder a la emergencia aunque algunas
alcaldías opositoras denuncian que están
en total abandono por motivaciones
políticas las pérdidas económicas son
tremendas el primer huracán dejó
pérdidas que rondan los 172 millones de
dólares y se espera que con éxito en
este segundo huracán yo está las
pérdidas se duplican y rondarían un
aproximado del 30 por ciento del
producto interno bruto del país también
afectaciones
estructura han sido enormes marcas y 800
fuentes y caminos fueron afectados
debido a estas dos tormentas que
afectaron muy seguido con 14 días de
diferencia solamente jorge esto en
cuanto al caso de nicaragua pero también
otros países de la región se ha visto se
han visto muy afectados por el paso de
estos dos huracanes guatemala el
salvador honduras y bueno ustedes hay en
nicaragua pero ha habido mucha
solidaridad entre los países para
apoyarse en esta situación tan difícil
cuál es la situación entonces en el
resto de la región
bueno a nivel regional ambos huracanes
dejaron aproximadamente más de 40
fallecidos y realizaron la evacuación de
cientos y miles de personas en países
como honduras panamá el salvador y
nicaragua
estos huracanes provocaron lluvias que
están teniendo gran afectación en la
producción agropecuaria específicamente
en contiguos como frijoles maíz maní y
hortalizas tan solo acá édgar agua se
habla de que la afectación de la
producción agrícola podría rondar el 30
por ciento
jorge de nuevo en el caso de nicaragua
cómo está avanzando allí el tema de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 hay muy poca
información sobre la situación en ese
país porque precisamente el gobierno de
daniel ortega
ha dejado simplemente que el virus tenga
su curso y son los ciudadanos los que
han tenido que tomar algunas venidas por
su cuenta pero no ha habido
restricciones por parte del gobierno
entonces tampoco hay mucha información
en cuanto a las medidas que está tomando
el gobierno para comprar estas vacunas
porque si se va a ir con la de eeuu la
china la de rusia y que negociaciones se
está adelantando
hay poca información respecto a estas
negociaciones y también a la vacuna en
específico lo que sí se sabe que por
ejemplo la vacuna que desarrolló la
farmacéutica pfiezer es muy difícil que
las condiciones logísticas permitan que
se mueva en países como nicaragua según
los especialistas debido a que para
transportar esta vacuna se necesita un
rango de temperaturas de entre menos 70
a menos 80 grados celsius y las
condiciones de frío en nicaragua rondan
entre el -3 y el menos 8 grados celsius
en agosto pasado el gobierno de
nicaragua anunció con bombos y platillos
que en un laboratorio que se llama
merchán y con un laboratorio ruso que
está ubicado en managua de cual se
maneja con mucho secretismo se estaría
comenzando a producir esta vacuna rusa
sin embargo algunos expertos consultados
aseguran que esta posibilidad es
improbable y poco se ha sabido del
avance de la producción de la vacuna acá
en managua jorge me queda tiempo para
hacerle una pregunta adicional y es el
resto de la región de américa latina
está en el proceso de la apertura y se
prepara para la posible segunda ola que
podría llegar
del año 2021 o a finales de este esto
viendo el espejo que nos ha mostrado
europa pero nicaragua nunca tuvo
confinamiento no tuvo restricciones la
gente continuó con su vida relativamente
normal y como yo decía son los
ciudadanos los que han tomado sus
propias precauciones para evitar ser
contagiados cómo está la situación
entonces en nicaragua ahora cuando todo
el continente está en el proceso de
apertura y tratando de estabilizar la
economía como ésta nicaragua
definitivamente el discurso de la
normalidad
y de las cifras bajas que ha brindado el
gobierno ha calado la población
nicaragüense hoy se pueden observar en
las calles de todo el país cierta
normalidad inclusive el uso de las
mascarillas que se promovió de forma
auto convocada por la ciudadanía ha
disminuido muchísimo
como bien lo mencioné antes nunca se
cerró en algún tipo de actividades o se
promovió algún tipo de confinamiento y
en menos ahora inclusive en medio de la
emergencia el día de hoy el gobierno
estaba anunciando diversas actividades
que promovió durante toda la pandemia y
que continúa promoviendo ahora mismo
pese a la invertirse que ha ocasionado
estos dos huracanes y que también según
los especialistas persiste el riesgo de
contagio porque porque la población ha
bajado la guardia y ha normalizado la
situación del por jorge muchas gracias
por este completo reporte desde la
ciudad de managua la capital de
nicaragua dándonos informaciones no
solamente de este país sino también de
la región de centroamérica que como lo
decíamos hace frente a dos emergencias
en este momento
y después de cerca de siete meses y
medio de cierre el aeropuerto
internacional josé martí de la ciudad de
la habana en cuba reinicio sus
operaciones de vuelos comerciales la
decisión de poner en marcha de nuevo las
operaciones coincide con el inicio de la
temporada turística de diciembre y enero
debido a la emergencia sanitaria por la
pandemia los turistas deberán pagar un
impuesto sanitario adicional que servirá
para cubrir los costos adicionales de
las nuevas normativas de higiene que
tiene cuba las autoridades cubanas no
exigirán a los viajeros pruebas de
coronavirus para el ingreso al país pero
sí habrá estrictas medidas de
bioseguridad para permanecer entrar y
permanecer en la terminal aérea de ese
aeropuerto nosotros estamos ya hace
varios meses queriendo regresar y no
podemos porque no había vuelo y estaba
todo cerrado el aeropuerto y que bueno
ya pudimos regresar y aquí está muy
contento de regresar a casa muy seguro
es lo que he podido ver hasta ahora
bueno ya veremos cuando vayan pasando
los días y todo en la medida que vaya
entrando turista en la medida que vayan
saliendo más si logran mantener este
tipo de procedimientos hasta ahora de lo
veo muy bueno y es muy preocupante el
caso de méxico este país superó los
100.000 fallecidos y de esta forma es el
cuarto país a nivel mundial en superar
ese umbral de las 100.000 víctimas por
cuenta del cob y 19 solamente después de
estados unidos brasil e india- la cifra
es dar a conocer pocos días después de
que también superará la barrera del
millón de casos de contagio desconcierta
la declaración del gobierno de mexico
que indicó que debido al sub diagnóstico
las cifras de muertos y contagiados
podrían ser mucho mayores veamos
méxico sumó otro triste hito en la
pandemia cuatro días después de superar
el millón de casos el país rompió la
barrera de las 100 mil muertes tras
reportar 576 en las últimas 24 horas es
el cuarto país en sumar esa cantidad de
fallecimientos después de estados unidos
brasil e india- una cifra preocupante e
impactante incluso para los altos cargos
de salud esta es una cantidad desde
luego
e inusual no tenía ningún antecedente
previo la sociedad mexicana de una
enfermedad infecciosa aguda que pudiera
causar una propagación tan rápida y
afectar la vida de tantas personas
aunque las autoridades señalan que los
decesos presentan una tendencia a la
baja los casos están repuntando en
algunas partes del país como el estado
de chihuahua en la frontera norte que
regresó al nivel máximo de alerta
la situación también empeoró en ciudad
de méxico que permanece en el segundo
nivel de alerta el gobierno local ha
dispuesto carpas móviles para realizar
pruebas entre los ciudadanos los
profesionales de la salud piden no bajar
la guardia es muy importante que esto lo
tomen en serio no es un juego uno de
este lado se esfuerza por brindarles la
protección las medidas de información y
las tomas de muestra pero si uno como
persona no hace caso no acata las
instrucciones de nada sirve y al
contrario los contagios van a la alta
los especialistas advierten que existe
una división entre los mexicanos entre
aquellos que descuidan las medidas de
protección y los que entran rápidamente
en pánico también señalan que la
cercanía de las fiestas ha incentivado a
los ciudadanos a salir a hacer compras
aumentando la cantidad de personas en
las calles y el riesgo de contagio
vamos a conocer más detalles con mario'
carbonell nuestro corresponsal en ciudad
de méxico hola mario y gracias por estar
con nosotros nuevamente aquí en kobe 19
y cuál es la postura y qué respuesta da
el gobierno de andrés manuel lópez
obrador frente a esta situación que es
muy preocupante como ya lo decíamos por
estas altas cifras que está presentando
méxico tanto de fallecidos como de
contagiados
qué tal si el gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador ha defendido la estrategia
ante el coronavirus a pesar de las
cifras que ya como bien dice rebasaron
los 100 mil muertos el presidente ha
dicho que corresponde hacer lo que han
hecho que ha dado resultados y su
argumento es que se ha fortalecido el
sistema hospitalario que su
administración heredó una red
hospitalaria en ruinas y que en muy poco
tiempo ha fortalecido pues la capacidad
de admisión de pacientes en los
hospitales
además también con el convenio que ha
hecho con la iniciativa privada para que
los hospitales particulares reciban en
una primera instancia a pacientes con
padecimientos distintos al cob y para
evitar la saturación y ahora en una
segunda instancia ya están recibiendo
también pacientes afectados por el
coronavirus ha dicho el presidente que
quienes están al frente de la estrategia
en este caso el subsecretario hugo lópez
gatell y el secretario jorge alcocer son
las personas más indicadas que son las
más capacitadas y reconocidas a nivel
mundial y también por supuesto en el
mundo de la academia y que han hecho un
trabajo extraordinario se queja de que
los adversarios a su gobierno los
opositores han aprovechado desde un
inicio la pandemia para golpear a su
administración y para señalar que son
culpables también se ha quejado del
manejo que algunos medios de
comunicación le han dado a la situación
recientemente después embistió al el
periódico 'el país' por un titular de
precisamente que hablaba de los 100.000
muertos y bueno dijo que el país fue un
periódico que defendió a las empresas
españolas durante el periodo neoliberal
en fin él asegura que se está haciendo
lo correcto sin embargo bueno pues hay
quienes opinan lo contrario es el caso
del bloque de gobernadores de oposición
son 10 mandatarios estatales agrupados
en la alianza federalista
pues justamente después de darse a
conocer esta cifra de los 100.000
muertos han expresado una vez más que es
necesario revisar a fondo la estrategia
y en su caso hacer los ajustes
pertinentes se quejan de que el
personaje que está atendiendo la
emergencia no está haciendo las cosas a
la altura -mario justamente como el
gobierno federal ha tomado pocas medidas
sobre todo después de la reapertura
económica y social que ha tenido méxico
los estados si han empezado a tomar
medidas para proteger a sus habitantes
en sus diferentes territorios también
incluso los alcaldes de algunas
localidades y ciudades cuáles han sido
algunas de estas medidas
así es cada estado ha tomado sus propias
medidas al margen de lo dispuesto en la
federación un ejemplo muy claro es las
disposiciones para el uso del cubrebocas
en algunos estados los congresos
estatales han aprobado leyes para hacer
obligatorio el uso de cubrebocas en la
vía pública como son chihuahua nuevo
león sonora zacatecas jalisco guanajuato
que establecen multas económicas o
incluso arresto los días o las horas de
arresto varía en función de cada estado
pero si están tomando medidas más
coercitivas por así llamarlo y también
están aplicando otro tipo de acciones
como el cierre de algunos
establecimientos comerciales aquí en la
ciudad de mexico la jefa de gobierno
claudia sheinbaum ha dicho que es una
ciudad de libertades y que nunca van a
imponer ningún tipo de sanción por no
usar cubrebocas sin embargo si se
aplican otras acciones como por ejemplo
la ley seca de prohibir la venta de
bebidas alcohólicas los fines de semana
comenzará
alternada 8 de las 16 alcaldías una
semana y luego las otras 8 porque han
identificado que es en las reuniones
privadas en las fiestas de más de 10
personas donde se producen focos de
contagio asimismo han reducido los
horarios de apertura de los
establecimientos comerciales no
esenciales a las 17 horas a fin pues de
evitar que la gente esté fuera de sus
casas cuando no es estrictamente
necesario también tiene un convenio con
el sector privado para establecer un
código qr para monitorear mejor a la
población y se duplicaron las pruebas en
los quioscos para tomar precisamente los
exámenes anti con mario' le hago la
misma pregunta del parque porque estamos
haciendo balance sobre el tema de las
vacunas en méxico cómo está avanzando
esta negociación qué novedades hay
ya están aplicándose algunas pruebas
experimentales de la vacuna de moderna y
de la de cancino que es esta alianza
china canadiense en algunos sectores de
la población de ciertos estados es el
caso de la ciudad de méxico también en
guerrero ya se están aplicando estas
pruebas con voluntarios sobre todo y
bueno el canciller marcelo ebrard que es
quien ha llevado toda esta negociación
ha insistido en que méxico pues forma
parte del mecanismo kóvacs facility lo
que le garantiza al país un acceso al
fármaco cuando esté listo estamos
hablando de la vacuna de astrazéneca y
oxford para la cual incluso méxico
participa en la producción a través del
gobierno y de la fundación carlos slim
pero también acuerdos con otras vacunas
es el caso por ejemplo de la china como
ya decía cancino y también hay acuerdos
de compra de posible compra de la vacuna
de facer aunque como en el caso de otros
países el problema de la vacuna de facer
es la necesidad de
a temperaturas muy bajas de
ultracongelación lo que representa sin
duda una un obstáculo logístico pero la
esperanza sin duda está fijada en la
vacuna y en los acuerdos que se tienen
para garantizarla en la población
mariah muchas gracias por este reporte
desde ciudad de mexico vamos a continuar
con otros temas en eeuu la pandemia está
avanzando cada vez más rápido en solo
una semana aumentó en un millón el
número de contagiados para llegar
entonces a una cifra total superior a
los 11 millones de casos diagnosticados
las víctimas ya superan los 250 mil esto
mientras las cifras de personas también
ingresadas en los hospitales sigue
aumentando de manera alarmante este es
el panorama veamos
los cuerpos sin vida siguen llegando
incluso las diez morgues móviles están
alcanzando su tope tanto así que en el
paso texas los reclusos de las cárceles
fueron contratados para transportar las
pilas de muertos los hospitales están
llenos han tenido que transferir
pacientes y cerca de cinco mil
trabajadores de la salud adicionales
fueron desplegados en todo el estado
y texas no es la única jurisdicción con
un vertiginoso aumento de casos el virus
se está propagando en los 50 estados la
zona del medio oeste es la más afectada
sobre todo en los estados que siguen a
donald trump pues no se ha reforzado el
uso de tapabocas ni el distanciamiento
social
ya que yo no creo que el virus sea tan
grave
ellos exageran lo agrandan más de lo que
es
como en texas arizona tampoco ha
impuesto un mandato de uso de tapabocas
el gobernador le sugirió a los
residentes utilizarlos pero eso no duró
mucho por el choque de opiniones los que
lo apoyan y los que no one sight what's
the black bird and gown algunos quieren
un cierre total y por otro algunos creen
que todo es una farsa
poulter lauren bacall ambos grupos son
muy vocales la mayoría de las personas
no apoyan estas opiniones
con el uso de tapabocas a un politizado
eeuu superó el umbral de las 250.000
muertes por kobe 19 ahora tiene el rango
de muertes más alto del mundo a lo largo
del país las filas de pruebas de
diagnóstico son largas las últimas dos
semanas los casos se incrementaron en un
79% superando un millón de contagios en
tan solo seis días
vamos a conocer detalles de la situación
allí en eeuu no es nada fácil lo que se
está viviendo allí
mam en sala en la ciudad de nueva york
muy buenas noches mamen el estado de
nueva york es donde usted se encuentra
anunció el cierre de las escuelas entre
otras medidas mamen que más ha impuesto
allí el gobierno local
son muy buenas noches santiago pues si
las autoridades de nueva york ya lo
habían advertido que si la tasa de
infección superaba el 3% durante siete
días consecutivos las 1.700 escuelas
públicas que hay en la ciudad cerraría
sus puertas y así ha ocurrido así es una
medida que de momento no se sabe hasta
cuándo va a durar lo que sí que ha dicho
el alcalde bill de blasio es que espera
que sea algo temporal hasta que la
situación mejore y de momento hay
300.000 alumnos que han vuelto a esa
enseñanza en remoto cuando no hace ni
ocho semanas que las escuelas abrieron
sus puertas esto que ha dado aquí ha
dado lugar pues a que salte la polémica
hay muchos padres que no entienden por
qué sus hijos no pueden ir al colegio
mientras que los restaurantes y
gimnasios siguen abiertos y precisamente
a estos comercios es a los que también
se les están imponiendo algunas
restricciones para frenar ese avance del
virus que se ha hecho pues bien
se les ha impuesto un toque de queda a
restaurantes y gimnasio es a partir de
las 10 de la noche tienen que cerrar sus
puertas y aquí llega la situación más
preocupante y es que
bill de blasio ya ha dicho que si la
situación continúa empeorando y los
casos continúan aumentando los gimnasios
y el interior de los restaurantes serán
los siguientes en cerrar una situación
pues que preocupa mucho sobre todo
porque aquí como sabéis en nuevayork esa
reapertura económica ha sido mucho más
lenta que en otros estados no ha pasado
ni dos meses desde que comenzaron a
abrir y en gimnasios y restaurantes sólo
está permitido abrir a un 30 y 25 por
ciento por lo que las pérdidas
económicas están siendo muy cuantiosas y
los empresarios los propietarios de
estos negocios ya han pedido a las
autoridades que si preparan que si están
anunciando que se van a cerrar las
puertas de estos comercios otra vez que
tengan también un plan de ayuda
económica para todos los trabajadores
que se van a quedar sin sus empleos amén
y hacemos lupa en el estado de nueva
york precisamente porque en la primera
ola de contagio fue precisamente el foco
de contagio en eeuu y por eso hay que
hacerle seguimiento es importante ver
cómo va evolucionando poco a poco la
situación allí pero esto es en cuanto a
la costa este
pero qué hay de los estados que están en
el pacifico california que es uno de los
más poblados qué medidas han
implementado allí porque también la tasa
de contagio allí está disparada
sin santiago la situación en california
la verdad es que desgraciadamente no es
mucho mejor de hecho se están batiendo
récords de contagios que no se veían
desde el mes de julio superando incluso
los 13 mil nuevos infectados diarios y
además según las autoridades el virus
está avanzando mucho más rápido de lo
que avanzó al principio de la pandemia
esto aquí ha dado lugar a que como dice
se hayan tenido que imponer nuevas
restricciones o endurecer las que ya
había por ejemplo restaurantes bares y
lugares de culto que se encuentren en la
zona púrpura porque el estado de
california como ocurre también aquí en
nueva york se está repartiendo por
colores para ver la gravedad de la
situación pues bien esa zona púrpura
indica que los contagios están
disparados como por ejemplo está
ocurriendo en los ángeles y en estos
casos estos comercios van a tener que
cerrar sus puertas en caso de que estén
en zonas naranjas por ejemplo que es un
nivel de contagio un poco más moderado
se permitirán que las tengan abiertas
pero con muchas restricciones también
desde este fin de semana se impone el
toque de queda nocturno eso que
significa que desde las 10 de la noche
hasta las 5 de la mañana
no se puede salir a la calle en al menos
41 condados que incluyen aquellas zonas
que están más pobladas como por ejemplo
los ángeles
esta nueva restricción de momento se
mantendrá hasta el 21 de diciembre y si
las cosas no mejoran se podría alargar
una situación como digo muy preocupante
que ha llegado incluso a imponer el uso
de la mascarilla también en zonas al
aire libre en cualquier momento salvo
que la persona que se encuentre sola o
bien esté al aire libre y no haya nadie
cercana a él al menos dos metros algo
que preocupa mucho a las autoridades
sanitarias en california y en el resto
del país santiago las celebraciones de
la próxima semana de cens vivendi ahí es
donde están ahora mismo todos los ojos
puestos precisamente por esa fecha
importante es la festividad tal vez una
de las más importantes en eeuu el día de
acción de gracias qué medidas han
impuesto las autoridades cómo va a ser
celebrado este año habrá restricciones
que han dicho los diferentes gobiernos
y si algo han visto las autoridades
sanitarias es que después de una
celebración aumentan los casos y eso es
lo que se va a tratar de evitar en estas
celebraciones de la semana que viene que
es acción de gracias' lo que se conoce
aquí como sense que viene entonces desde
los centros de prevención y control de
enfermedades ya han advertido a nova han
ofrecido han publicado una serie de
recomendaciones entre las que están pues
no viajar y si se tiene que viajar
porque no queda otra que se haga con
todas las garantías que pasan por el uso
de la mascarilla y el desinfectante de
manos están pidiendo también a la
población que trate de no a reunirse a
muchas personas para esa celebración
para esa cena del día de acción de
gracias y que si lo hacen sea al aire
libre y cada uno llevando su propia
comida y sus propios utensilios y por
supuesto el uso de mascarilla en todo
momento en un menú momento en el que los
casos continúan aumentando también
muchas gracias por este completo reporte
desde la ciudad de nueva york- buen fin
de semana vamos a irnos ahora entonces
hasta el extremo sur en argentina un
bloque de diputados oficialistas
en un proyecto de ley que busca recaudar
unos 3.750 millones de dólares para
ayudar a los más afectados por la
pandemia este recaudo sería a través de
un aporte único de las grandes fortunas
de ese país suramericano
de concretarse entonces el presidente
alberto fernández podría contar con esos
fondos para afrontar la caída de la
actividad económica y de la recaudación
fiscal causadas por la pandemia del
coronavirus
es cínico venía acá hablando en defensa
de las pymes que a mí me va a pagar un
impuesto
sobre riquezas que están grabadas de 200
millones para arriba y para que hace
falta esto
hace falta esto para tener los recursos
que el estado tuvo que poner para pagar
ife atp si les pagamos el salario a
muchos trabajadores y esas grandes
empresas que van a tener que pagar ahora
bueno que devuelvan un poquito de la
ayuda que le dio el estado en nuestra
sección en redes veamos otras noticias
destacadas de la semana aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa canadá está
considerando donar las dosis extras de
vacunas contra kobe 19 a varios países
del tercer mundo este país
norteamericano ha hecho tratos para
comprar más dosis per cápita que
cualquier otra nación reservando
suficientes para vacunar a los
canadienses varias veces el excedente
será donado a otros países menos
favorecidos de la región el anuncio
tiene lugar luego de que las autoridades
de la ciudad de toronto también
anunciarán que a partir de la otra
semana la ciudad y la región de
influencia regresarán a un confinamiento
sectorizado ante el rápido incremento de
los casos de kobe el 19
belice guyana rompen los son récords de
víctimas de kobe 19 estos países se unen
a otros que también están dando una gran
cantidad de casos positivos belice y
guyana rompieron los récords de víctimas
entre los estados de la comunidad
caribeña caricom ambos países tienen una
infraestructura hospitalaria muy
reducida belice con tan solo 400.000
habitantes tiene más de 5 mil casos
reportados más de 100 personas ya han
fallecido allí guyana que tiene 780 mil
habitantes podría llegar en los próximos
días ya a los 5 mil casos hayan perdido
la vida 140 personas
y en la ya mencionada carrera por la
vacuna la farmacéutica pfiezer y su
socia la alemana valiente que anunciaron
que solicitarán autorización para el uso
de emergencia de su vacuna ante el
organismo regulador de salud en eeuu
esto después de confirmar que su vacuna
tiene una efectividad del 95 por ciento
hoy es un día histórico un día histórico
para la ciencia y para todos nosotros
tomó solo 248 días desde que anunciamos
planes para colaborar con blake hasta la
fecha de nuestra petición a la fda
hemos operado a una velocidad
extraordinaria en nuestro programa de
desarrollo clínico desde el concepto
hasta la petición regulatoria siempre
manteniendo el enfoque en la seguridad
por foxconn se estaba cura de facer
tiene una efectividad superior al 95 por
ciento las otras dos que están en fase 3
ya llegan al 90% pero hay otras ocho
vacunas que están todavía en ese proceso
veamos cómo está la actualización desde
el desarrollo de esta vacuna
en la carrera por la vacuna contra el
coronavirus entra en su recta final
fighters moderna expande 5 y así hasta
48 vacunas se encuentran actualmente en
desarrollo la lucha contra el kobe 19 11
de ellas se encuentran en la fase 3 de
desarrollo y tres fabricantes anunciaron
esta semana que su vacuna tiene una
eficacia superior al 90 por ciento según
los expertos la vacuna del fabricante
fighter y su socio billón tec es la
mejor situada hasta la fecha con una
eficacia probada del 95 por ciento
tenemos que entender que se trata de un
nuevo agente patógeno y no sabíamos nada
de él cuando comenzamos el desarrollo de
la vacuna hemos sido capaces de
desarrollar esta vacuna en unos 10 meses
y esta es una velocidad extraordinaria y
una eficacia extraordinaria así que las
expectativas de los expertos en este
campo eran de una tasa de eficacia en el
rango del 60 al 75 por ciento el 95 por
ciento está por supuesto más allá de esa
expectativa de éxito
este jueves la revista médica lancet
publica también los nuevos resultados de
la vacuna de la universidad de oxford
está demostrado ser segura en personas
mayores sanas y provocar respuesta
inmune al virus ahora deberá confirmar
los datos en la última fase de
desarrollo mientras tanto china enviado
ya a través de turquía el primer lote de
su vacuna hacia brasil en donde
terminarán de hacerse pruebas de su
eficacia la mayoría de países se
preparan ahora para una pronta
vacunación masiva tras una carrera que
hace tiempo se convirtió en una lucha
geopolítica
y brasil país que ya superó esta semana
los 6 millones de casos confirmados son
recibió las primeras 120 mil dosis de la
vacuna coronaba que se trata entonces de
un total de 6 millones de dosis que
fueron adquiridas por brasil a china
para comenzar a hacer inoculadas de
forma masiva a partir del mes de enero
en ese país suramericano
y así llegamos al final de kobe 19 la
semana en américa pueden seguir los
desarrollos de estas noticias a través
de nuestra página web france24 puntocom
también en las redes sociales y en la
app descargando en su dispositivo móvil
nos vemos la próxima semana feliz fin de
semana para todos
[Música]